let's see if we can extend the path
counting brain teaser to three
dimensions
so let's say that i had a three by three
cube i'll keep it at three by three to
keep the math from getting too hairy so
let me draw it like that i won't use the
line tool just because
well
maybe i should have
so let's see the front of the cube looks
something like that
that's the front of the cube and the
cube goes backwards like that
comes down
goes like that it's a three by three
like a rubik's cube
yeah i could have drawn this a little
bit better but i think this will
meet our needs
okay
there you go three by three cube
and so our goal is to get from
this back left cube this top corner
back left cube and get to
this front bottom right cube so this is
our goal i'll do it in this yellow this
is our goal right there
and we are allowed to either go forward
from any cube these are our three
operations or three movements we can do
we can go forward
or i guess towards the front
we could go
down
we could go down
or we could go to the right so i can't
draw it here oh i could right here we
could go from that cube to that cube so
just like the two-dimensional problem
you're only allowed to make forward
progress you're not allowed to come down
here and then go down over here you're
allowed to go down here then here but
then you're not allowed to go up so
every step you're getting a little bit
closer from
this
back left top cube
to this front
front bottom right cube and so the same
question applies how many different ways
are there to get from there
to there and you can pause it now and
try it yourself because i'm about to
explain how to do it and the first thing
you know when you try to do it yourself
is to to realize that boy this is hard
to visualize even if i had to draw this
out it will have to go in and out i mean
how do i even visualize a a
three-dimensional cube like this and and
and the best way to do it is to
separately visualize each of the
separate layers so let's do that let's
make this the
magenta layer
up here we'll call that layer one so
this is the magenta layer up here
and you'll see what i'm doing in a
second
this is the
i don't know the move
layer
right there
the move layer
and then finally i'll do
i'll do the orange layer
the orange layer is that one right there
we can do is separately draw each of
these layers
so first let's do the magenta layer so
the magenta layer will look like this
and now i'll use things that help nope
not like that i want to use the other
tool
the magenta
layer me draw some squares in here
and it's like that and like that
and like that
and then let me the middle one was the
move layer let me draw that
the move layer looks something like that
remember it's like you can imagine i'm
slicing it and just looking at it from
above that's the idea here and it's
going to help us visualize this problem
so the move layer looks something like
that
and then finally the orange layer
orange
layer
looks like this and we're almost ready
to actually start doing the problem
good enough so just to make sure we
understand our visualization this layer
up here we call that layer one that you
could put this is box one
this layer is
layer two let's say so i'll put a little
two here and i don't wanna get these
confused with the paths and all that so
i'm writing it really small and this is
layer three or level 3 and that's right
there and just to make sure you
understand this corner right there this
is our start point and that's right
there
right because this is the whole top so
this is the back left of the top
and our finish point the bottom right
is right here
so essentially our problem goes from how
many ways to get from there to there to
how many ways to get from there to there
so let's just stay within a layer so how
many ways can i get to this point right
here well i can only go from this point
and go straight in the layer like that
so there's only one way to get there
right that movement is the exact same
movement as this right here
going from this box to this box there's
one way to get there that's the same
thing as there and similarly i could go
there and i could just go one more step
so there's only one way to get there and
that's like going like there and then
there
and by the same logic i could go one to
the right here that's the only way to
get there i could go two to the right
there and that's the only way to get
there
and now if you watch the if you watch
the the two-dimensional path counting
brain teaser you know that there's
two ways to get here and the logic is
well you could draw it out you could go
like that one two and that's the same
thing as going
as saying 1
it's easier to visualize here but the
general logic was well to know how many
ways to get to any square think about
the squares that lead to it and how many
ways can i get to those two squares and
then sum them up right and by the same
logic so there's two ways to get here
that's that cell
three ways to get here right two plus
one is three one plus two is three and
three plus 3 is 6. so there are six ways
to get to this
cube right there from that one so this
isn't too different from the
two-dimensional problem so far but now
it gets interesting
so how many ways
i'll just do it i did this in yellow but
i should have done in the color of that
layer how many ways are there to get to
this cell right here this cell is
is that one right there
well i start here and i can just go
straight down right there's i mean
there's only one way to be there but i
go straight down so there's only one way
to get there
right actually let's extend there's only
one way to get here if i'm going
straight down
and so there's only one way to get to
this cell too i'd have to go straight
down again
so there's only one way to get there
hopefully you understand the kind of the
way we're visualizing it this is the
bottom row and there's only one way you
have to go you go from here straight
down to there straight down to there and
that's the only way to get there
fair enough
now hot this is where it gets
interesting how many ways are there to
get to this cell
well in our old example there was only
one way in two dimensions to go from
this cell but now we can go from this
cell and we could come from above and
whereas above above is right there
so now we add this cell to that cell so
one plus one is there are two ways to
get there
how many ways to get to this
you can't even see this kind of in the
back middle
of this of this cube how many ways to
get there well there's two ways to come
from this direction and i can also come
from above right there so two plus one
is three
how many ways to get here well one from
behind and then one from above so that's
two and you see a little bit of symmetry
and how many ways to come here well
there's two here from going straight
forward
right two ways to go that way and then
one way to come from above
and that's that one way oh no that we're
on this cell so there's
if we are so we're no we're actually
this is 2 and we're on this cell so if
we want to know how many ways to get to
this cell there's two ways
to go from there and then one way from
above that's three
and now
right here
how many ways to get to this cell
there's three ways i could come from
here from here
or
from above
or from above so i have the two plus two
plus two
is six
likewise here six i could come from six
plus three is nine but i can also come
from above from here so there's 12 ways
to get there
and you can do the same logic how many
ways to get here well within the same
row there are nine ways
right 6 plus 3 is 9 and then you can
come from above as well that's 12.
and then finally how many ways to get to
this cell right here which is this one
right there
well i could come from there's 12 ways
to get here
so i can go all of those ways 12 ways to
come from behind it says 24 and then 6
ways to come from above
right so 12 plus 12 is 24 plus 6 is 30.
i think you're seeing the pattern
so how many ways to get here well it's 1
plus two which is three
how many ways to get here
well it's three plus three which is six
how many ways to get here it's one way
here and two from above so it's three
how many ways to get here well three
from behind and three from above that's
six
here it's three plus three is six but
you could also come from above so six
again
so that is twelve
how many ways to get here twelve plus 6
is 18 but i could there's 12 ways to
come from above as well so 18 plus 12 is
and by the same logic there's 18 ways to
get here from these two cells but i
could also come from above
so that is 30.
so how many ways to get to this last
cell where there's 30 from this
direction 30 ways from there 30 ways
from behind it that's 60
and then there's another 30 ways to come
from above so there are 90 ways
there are 90 ways i could write that
there but you can't see it 90 ways
to get from
that cell over there to this cell over
here and in the last video i made the
analogy to the binomial theorem and i'll
i'll leave you to think about what the
three-dimensional analogy is and i'll
throw out a word which you which is
never really mentioned in math class
because it's normally too hairy to deal
with think about formulating a trinomial
theorems to help you multiply things
like x
plus y
plus z to the n power and think about
how this cube were an extension of it
this is a 3 by 3 by
this is a 3 by 3 cube but imagine if it
was a or 3 by 3 by 3 q but imagine if it
was you know an n by n by n cube then
you can start you know taking things to
arbitrary powers so i'll let you to
leave you to think about this but i just
thought this was a a neat visualization
problem which is really not any more
difficult than the last one actually
before i leave you i'll leave you with
just a general principle and this is
actually really useful for some
standardized tests or just logic games
is
if i'm trying to get to that to this
cell and let's say i have a bunch of
other you know
whoops i didn't want to do that let's
say there's a bunch of ways to get here
and it has to have direction
so i won't go into a whole graph theory
thing because but it has to have
direction and you can't have cycles you
can't go because then you could have an
infinite ways to get to a certain point
and let's say that there are
x ways to get there y ways to get there
z ways to get there and i don't know a
ways to get there i'll cycle through the
alphabet and you know this is just a
subset of the larger graph right this
graph could have you know a bunch of
just you know you know connections this
is just
where we are and these are all of the
nodes that connect to this the general
rule that we've learned in the last two
brain teasers is you just you say okay
how can i get to this node
well i can go from here here here here
and i just have to add up so if i can
get from here there's x ways to come via
this node y ways to come via that node z
ways to come via that node a ways to
come via that node so the total ways to
get to that node is
x plus y plus z plus a and you can
actually you'll see problems like this
if you ever plan on becoming a lawyer
they actually do have problems like this
on the lsat that aren't maybe as
complicated what we did here but you you
need to understand this principle anyway
hope you enjoyed that